[Music]
It's God. It's
God. It's
God. Putting it fully. So if we go to
James, we're going to see what James
says. We're going to read it in this
context. I got it right here, brother.
So it says here, it says,
"Let no one say when he is tempted, I am
being tempted by God. For God cannot be
tempted with evil." Thank you. So the
devil let me let me finish let me finish
the devil let me finish let me finish
okay go on go on and he himself tempts
no one but each person is tempted when
he is lured and enticed by his own
desire then desire when it has conceived
gives birth to sin and sin you haven't
read this part and sin when it is fully
grown brings forth death so so God can't
be tempted with evil there's no sinful
or evil desire within him that's why the
devil failed trying to do this with
Jesus. I agree with you. I agree with
you. Yeah. My question to you is when
Jesus was on earth, you believe he was
fully God and fully man. He was fully
God, fully man on earth. So, can God be
tempted? Yes. But according to James,
but not by evil. Not by evil. Would the
devil tempt good or evil? Yes or no? He
does all the time. What are you talking
about? Answer the question. Would the
devil tempt to do good or evil? He he
tempts to do evil. Of course, but he's
not being but he's not tempted by the
evil. Jesus is not tempted by evil. When
tempted, no one should say God is
tempted. For God cannot be tempted by
evil, nor does he tempt anyone. So, my
question is, was Jesus tempted by the
devil when he was fully man and fully
God on earth? Fully God. To answer your
question fully again, Jesus had no evil
in him. I did not. So, let me finish. I
asked you. Let me finishesus. Let me
allow me to finish. Let me finish. Was
Jesus I I let you We listen to you, bro.
We just listen to you. I heard your
question. We listen to you, right? I let
you speak already. I already speak. I I
let you
speak. No, I'm I'm showing the same
respect, right? Show the same respect.
Okay. All right. So, was Jesus tempted
by evil? No. No. That's why that's why
the devil failed. Jesus had Let me
finish answering you, brother. Look,
before you think of a response, just
listen to the answer. Okay, I appreciate
it. So, it's very clear what being
tempted by evil means. It says, "For
being tempted by evil, you have in your
own desires and being enticed by your
own desires and being alert." Oh my
goodness, dude. Are you okay? I know
you're on. Okay. Are you okay? Are you
okay?
It's It's okay, man. I apologize. It's
It's all Everybody panics real soon.
It's all good. I'm not sweating. Okay,
you are not. Okay, good. Okay, you
should call him up then. Maybe he can
tell you how his beer makes him a
different person.
I think they treat the person in the
Yeah. Yeah. Call call Libyan up. He'll
tell you that Jesus is God in a sense.
Yeah. You agree with him? Not according
to the
Okay. Don't Don't Anyway, there's
nothing to twist. All right. Let's get
back on track. Let's All right. So,
let's let's see how it defines tempting.
Listen, make sure you listen carefully,
okay?
But each person is tempted when he is
lured and enticed by his own desire. You
can only be tempted if you have your own
faulty desire within you. So because
Jesus had no inner desire of sin, no
sinful desire, nothing to be enticed, it
was impossible. Let me finish. Are you
let me finish you guys? Okay. He cannot
He cannot be tempted by evil, which is
why Satan failed. But can God be
tempted? Yes, in the sense of testing
God, which is why it says in the Old
Testament, you shall not put your Lord
God to the be tempted as you did in the
wilderness. Did you know that verse? Oh,
that's
funny. Did you hear that? It says, "You
shall not tempt the Lord your God as you
did in the wilderness." Go on. Would the
devil tempt his phone? Temptations all
around. Would the devil Would the devil
tempt his phone? Yes or no? No. No. See,
do you see? Would the devil thevil
There's no response now. This phone has
no life. He has no response. No desire.
So if Jesus did not have any desire, why
did Satan attempt to tempt Jesus if he
had no desire? Good question. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Notice he's not God, not
human. Notice how notice how brilliant
listen in the first place. Okay. You
know what? You know
what? If if the devil knew Jesus was
God, why would you talked to him, didn't
you? No, no, no. She was she was asking.
Okay. Yeah. And and I'm going to respond
to her now just like this. Okay. So, if
Jesus knew that Sat uh I'm sorry. If
Satan knew that Jesus is God, why would
he tempt him in the first place? Doesn't
he know he's God? Huh? The same devil
that challenged God in heaven and and
got all the angels to go against God.
Wait when when when when Satan
challenged God, did he really think he
could win? Oh, wait. So, hold on. Are we
Are we Are we Are we talking about Hold
on. Are we talking about the same stupid
entity that challenged God as if he was
going to win? Let me Let me finish,
brother. Why do you believe? Let me
finish. Let me finish.
There's a point here. There's a point
here. I'm showing you I'm showing you
how faulty that argument is that it's so
dumb. It's silly to ask if Satan knows
that Jesus is God, why would he
challenge him? He did it before. He's
doing it again. It means it's nothing.
Now, when it comes to temptation, we
already we already described what
temptation was. You thought you was so
brilliant. I agree. Would God would
Satan tempt this book? I agree. Is is
that really a good example? Is this is
it is this book conscious desire? Is it
Is it conscious? Does he have desire? Is
it conscious? No, it's not. Does he have
desire? So So therefore, let me finish
now. Let me finish. You're just my
point. You're bringing You're You're
bringing a point, bro. What you're doing
is called false equivocation. You
brought up an inanimate object, saying,
"Would Satan uh tempt this inanimate
object like he tempt Jesus?" Why did I
do that? Jesus has a mind. He has a
will. He has consciousness. He has
awareness. So because of that, we'll let
you finish. We'll let you finish. I
appreciate it. So So because of that,
this is a false equivocation. So yeah.
Oh, it is. I am. I am. So I need you to
respond to this. Temptation is having
evil desire within yourself and being
able to be lured away because you have
this desire in you already. Did Jesus
have evil desire in him already? Yes.
Show me the verse. Because the devil
Show me the verse. Wait, wait, wait,
wait. The devil, no. You define, you
define temptation as someone who has the
desire to commit evil. Now, I gave the
example. He gave the definition, not me.
So, can you show the verse where Jesus
had that in him? This phone doesn't have
the desire to commit evil. That's why
you're not going to tempt his phone. But
why did the devil tempt Jesus? Because
he knows Jesus is a human being who has
the desire to commit sins. Thank you
very much.
my point. I got you. It's okay. It's
okay. It's okay. So, so, so do me a
favor cuz you said yes. Jesus had evil
desire within himself that he could be
enticed and lured away by Satan. And so,
Satan tried to get tried to take
advantage of that. Can you show me the
verse where it says that Jesus had evil
in his heart? Because he's a human.
That's why. So, what are you tempted
evil every day? I I am. I am. You're a
human. You have a desire. This I'm not
Jesus. I'm not Jesus. I know you're not.
He's a human. Show me a verse. My point
is, show me a verse. My point is if the
devil understood that Jesus is fully God
and man on earth and he's exempt from
being desired, the Satan would not even
have the thought of
tempting the devil just like Adam. Why
was Adam tempted? Because he had the
desire to commit sin. Now the same with
Jesus Christ. The devil did not see
Jesus as God because God cannot be
tempted. But because the devil tempted
Jesus, the devil knows that he's a human
who has a desire. Now what you're doing
is I is Jesus. This is what you're
doing. You have your preconceived
notions of this hypothatic union concept
that is not in the Old Testament neither
in the New Testament. Now, now first
establish the
evidence phone. The devil is the
evidence that Jesus had the capacity to
commit the question. He had
desire. Does this phone have the desire
to commit sin?
Because guys, where where you where
heard you, brother? Where he Where you?
Where's your question? We just let you
go. We just heard you go. You're
welcome. Okay. Thank you. I appreciate
guys. Did Oh, he's about to run away
now. I got to pray. Okay. Guys, did you
guys hear a verse? Jesus. Y'all didn't
hear a verse. This is what you did last
time. Did y'all hear a verse? Okay.
Okay. So, so, so to be clear, hold on.
All right. Let me hold on. Let me get my
point off. So, we didn't we so we didn't
hear a verse where Jesus has sinful evil
desire within himself that Satan could
exploit. He didn't bring a single verse.
He made a claim. Hold on. Hold on, guys.
Let me do it. Don't Don't heckle him.
Don't heckle him. So, we didn't get a
verse. Now, he's saying he got a he gave
us a verse. I don't know. Maybe Allah
made it appear he got a verse or
something. I don't know. But, I didn't
hear a verse. Bro, I would like to hear
your turn. We'll see. We'll see. We'll
see. We'll see. So, so hold on. Hold on.
You're going to get your turn. You're
going to get your turn. You're going to
get your turn. You're going to get your
turn. So, according to what we just
broke down, temptation is having an evil
desire within you that you could be
lured away and enticed by. That's what
No, you don't because you just said that
Jesus has that in him and you couldn't
bring a verse. So, you're just yapping
now without bringing a verse. So, before
you do anything, bring a verse. That's
why. So guess what? So his So his thing
is, hold on. Satan tried to tempt Jesus.
He wouldn't try to tempt Jesus unless sa
Jesus could be tempted. Unless Jesus can
fall to his temptation. Just like if
that by that logic, Satan wouldn't
challenge God unless he actually could
win. Huh?
Okay. So what's the difference between
challenge and temptation? Oh, hold on.
You're talking about the difference,
sir. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. You're not
dealing with the point. You made the
claim. You're not dealing with the
point. The point your point is is that
Satan wouldn't do certain actions unless
he knows he can concede in it. He he can
succeed or be effective. No. That's your
point. So your point has the potential
to succeed. Let me finish. Okay. So So
is that what I just said? So all right.
So when Satan rebelled against God, did
he have the potential to defeat him?
Hey, thanks for coming, man.
Very good. Okay.
So notice this. They said, "Of course
not." They said, "Of course not." Why
did the devil They said, "Of course
not." Hold on a second. So you guys just
buried yourself. You don't know how. Oh,
I love I love this. Hold on. I
love you said the devil tempt the God.
You believe that Jesus is listen to what
I'm saying. Listen to the point. Okay.
So you he made the point with along with
you that Satan would not tempt Jesus if
unless he knew he could try to tempt
him. Right. Unless he had potential to
succeed. Exactly. So he wouldn't do
Satan wouldn't do anything unless he
thought that he could actually succeed
in that action. That's the principle he
says. Exactly. So I just asked you guys,
could Satan have possibly defeated God?
No. The answer is no. But however, Satan
challenged God as if he could defeat
him.
Hold on. Let me here's the
point. You're not getting it. When they
challenge God, brother, let me finish.
God, you're about to get it. You're
about to get it. You're about to get it.
No, it is. You're saying how stupid this
is. It is. It is. So by this principle,
Satan even does things and does actions
even when he can't succeed in it. Does
God have evil desire?
No. Satan's going to tempt God. Did you
just see the point? Evil desire. You
just see the point. You just got buried.
You just buried yourself. You just
buried
yourself. He didn't let
me hear. Did the devil tempt or tested
Jesus Christ? Yes. According to
Markapter 1, what does that prove? That
proves the devil didn't see Jesus as
God. He saw Jesus as a human. Just like
in Mark 6:4, Jesus is a prophet. Okay.
Now, what I'm doing is biblical
interpretation. What you're doing is
called biblical isoges. James
1:3 in the light of this verse. So,
please don't make your man-made
argument. Please substantiate that
within the Bible. Does Did Satan ask Did
Satan ask Jesus, "If you are the son of
God, then do then turn these bread into
the question, the tender stone in the
bread." You didn't answer my question.
You didn't answer my question. You know
what? I'm going to run away. Yeah, I
know you are. Have a good evening. Take
care. Bye, Coward. Byebye. Bye, Coward.
Bye.
Bye. Bye. You're done. You're done. He's
done. He's done. He's broke. I
wanted infinite
recess. It's
good. Judah and I hope you see
what you
see. I hope you see what your boy
did. The principal of his argument fell.
you. He said that Satan wouldn't do
something that he couldn't succeed in
but yet he challenged God. Silly believe
that Jesus can be tempted
just temptation. I don't believe that
he's speaking to you.
So long and behold, guys, this is what
we got. We got a complete runner over
here. He buried himself by his own
statement. He said if Satan knew that
Jesus was God, he wouldn't tempt him in
he wouldn't try to tempt him in the
first place. But the only reason why he
did it is because he thought he could
tempt him. Okay? So, Satan wouldn't do
something that he knows he wouldn't win
in. So, Satan be the same Satan that was
dumb enough to challenge God and act
like he can take over heaven is the same
dummy that tried to tempt Jesus and
failed. What are these idiots talking
about, man? Watch your hand, man.
It's God. It's God.
[Music]